le temps
[Musique]
notre grande menace d'une génération la
guerre du président poutine contre
l'ukraine
le peuple tu es d'ukraine
j savez fois j'ai détermination et
luttent pour leur liberté et leur avenir
nous sommes avec eux
toute résidence a indiqué
nous envoyer un message
on le remercions pour votre soutien
significatif
et soulignons l'importance vitale c'est
un soutien militaire accrue
aujourd'hui les dirigeants de l'otan se
sont mis d'accord que nous allons
fournir un soutien supplémentaire à
l'étranger nous continuerons à imposer
une sanction sans précédent sur la
russie et nous allons renforcer
les éléments
contre lui
nous avons approuvé quatre nouveaux
postes mouvements tactiques en bulgarie
roumanie hongrie et slovaquie
en plus de ce qui se situe déjà dans les
états baltes et la pologne donc il y a
huit
groupements tactiques
de la mer baltique jusqu'à la mer noire
en europe il y à cent mille
soldats américains
soutiennent des effets de l'étang et nos
alliés européens
contribuent également nous avons
quarante mille hommes sous commandement
direct de l'otan
avec une puissance aérienne et maritime
du nord jusqu'à la méditerranée
aujourd'hui les pays riches heures de
l'essence a mis d'accord tous
se regarder vers l'avenir pour faire
face à une nouvelle menace
sur terre nous aurons
plus de force dans la partie est de
l'alliance
dans cet état de préparation avec plus
d'équipements prépositionnés
dans les airs nous allons déployer plus
d'avions et renforcez nous défense
antiaérienne et antimissile au maire
nous aurons les sous marins et les
navires et un nombre significatif de
navires de combat de manière permanente
nous allons renforcer également de
cyberdéfense
améliorer nos exercices
nous focalisant sur notre défense
collective et l'interopérabilité
nous allons certainement
décidé de nous des détails lors de notre
prochain sommet à madrid au mois de juin
aujourd'hui nos dirigeants se sont mis
également d'accord pour fournir plus de
soutien à l'ukraine
pour les aider à défendre leurs droits
leur défense nous fournirons des
fournitures
militaires notamment des drones qui sont
très efficaces
nous fournirons également une aide
humanitaire substantielle est
aujourd'hui l'une s'est mis d'accord
pour faire clic ils compris une aide en
cyber
protection afin d'aider l'ukraine à se
prémunir contre des attaques biologiques
chimiques radiologiques et nucléaires
cela pourrait comprendre la détection la
protection des fournitures médicales
ainsi que la formation
pour la déco mination et la gestion de
crise nous sommes déterminés à faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour soutenir
du trait
favorablement les offres d'assistance
concrètes par nos alliés aux gens tous
dans le même temps mais nous avons la
responsabilité de s'assurer que ce
conflit
ne voit pas d'escalation
ce serait encore plus dangereux
et auraient un impact encore plus grave
les alès semble les alliés sont d'accord
que nous devons augmenter notre soutien
à d'autres partenaires mais c'est par la
russie
y compris la géorgie et la bosnie
herzégovine
travaillent ensemble avec l'union
européenne jeu devant les aider à
protéger leur souveraineté et renforcer
leur alliance
nous avons également parlé du rôle de
pékin dans cette crise nos dirigeants
ont demandé à la chine de ne pas
soutenir les efforts de guerre de la
russie la chine doit pas fuir une
assistance exxon et mifi militaire à
cette invasion russe chacun doit se
servir de son influence significative
sur la russie afin de promouvoir
une résolution immédiate à ce conflit
les alliés sont également d'accord
s'il ne faut pas agir en tant qu'allié à
cette invasion russe nous avons
réaffirmé notre engagement très fort à
la politique de la porte ouverte de
l'otan sur l'article 10 du traité de
washington
notre intervention a été une réussite
sans précédente pour la promotion de la
paix de démocratie en europe un mois
après le début de l'invasion de la
russie de l'ukraine
notre positionnement à l'otan a changé
pour le long terme nous répondant à
cette situation mais les sécurité
n'est pas gratuit ce faire plus coûtera
plus les dirigeants de l'otan se sont
mis d'accord pour redoubler d'efforts
afin
de relever ce défi et de respecter les
promesses faites en 2014 d'augmenter les
dépenses
nous parlerons du comment
respect à respecter ses promesses ici le
mois de juin ses alliés ont annoncé
aujourd'hui les plantes d'augmenter de
manière significative les budgets de
défense
la solidarité transatlantique est vital
l'europe et les états unis est fort
ensemble au sein de l'otan je suis prêt
à prendre vos questions oui cnn
merci monsieur le secrétaire général le
président de lens qui lorsqu'il a parlé
à l'otan a accusé la russie d'avoir
déployé des missiles au phosphore et
quelle serait la réponse est ce que vous
avez parlé lors de cette réunion la
positionnement permanente de force dans
les pays tels que les pays baltes et
d'abandonner l'acte fondateur entre
l'otan et la russie
nous remettons à jour les forces de
dissuasion de l'otan pour le long terme
avec plus d'actifs plus de soldats
nous avons déjà augmenter notre présence
à l'est nous avons mis en place quatre
nouveaux groupements techniques
elle nous allons discuter des options
pour une présence à plus long terme et
notre positionnement militaire
décideront des détails lors de notre
sommet au mois de juin mais c'est en
plus de ce que nous avons déjà fait
c'est pour le long terme
parce que
on peut dire aujourd'hui que
cette invention
russe de l'ukraine a changé
l'environnement sécuritaire pour le long
terme c'est une nouvelle réalité
c'est la nouvelle norme et le temps le
temps réponse pour le long terme
nous avons eu des informations crédibles
quant à l'utilisation
de forces militaires contre les civils
et cela nous inquiète grandement
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
selon vous comment le temps va répondre
si la chine soutient la russie de
manière économique éventuellement de
manière militaire est selon vous est ce
qu'il y a un rôle à jouer par le temps
lorsqu'il s'agit de
des prix de l'énergie notamment avec les
producteurs hors-opep
les alliés de l'otan coordonnent leurs
efforts cela comprend également la
sécurité énergétique nous en avons parlé
aujourd'hui
nous devons augmenter les sources
d'approvisionnement
et réduire la dépendance
de l'énergie provenant de la russie
il ya eu également la réunion du g7
qui travaille de concert avec l'union
européenne se mettre en place des
formats sont répondre à ces besoins de
renforcer la souveraineté énergétique et
réduire la dépendance au pétrole et gaz
russe notre message aux chine et que à
la chine et qui doivent condamner de
manière très claire cette guerre brutale
contre l'ukraine
et se met du côté du reste du monde
n'est pas su tenir la russie
ce soit avec un soutien économique ni
bien sûr un soutien militaire
je
n'aimerais pour vous demander c'est les
dirigeants polonais et elle a
aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont proposé d'envoyer une mission
et en ukraine l'inculte aide humanitaire
à ce qu'il y ait une décision
je suis nous avons parlé
diversité des questions qui devraient
rester unie et nous devons fournir ce
soutien l'ukraine dans le même temps
nous avons une responsabilité
se s'assurer que ce conflit
ne se transforme pas en guerre entre
l'otan et la russie
c'est également pour ça que les alliés
avec l'ail que nous n'allons pas déployé
des troupes sur le terrain on écrème
pour cela il faudrait être prêt à voir
un conflit entre la russie et le temps